[Music]
yes
this journey this road that i travel on
it all seems crazy over the years i
picked up thousands of tagalongs
inspired by my story from a juvenile
where my clothes had holes in them and
my afro is picky
to the nighties moschino and versace
no laces in her cheese new millennium
turn this on all right here we go
[Applause]
um
hi there um i don't have an appointment
uh i just wanted to speak to the manager
regarding what's happening in china and
as you know there's some uh
protests happening and we just wanted to
ask some questions because as you guys
know um
i haven't um but
yeah you know you know the process
that's happening outside i want to speak
to the manager because as you know
volkswagen has one of their factories in
china
the young province yeah i'm with them i
just want to speak to the manager to see
if he's aware of what's going on because
there are
muslims chinese well uh legal muslims
who are in camps
and being forced labor and when they
asked your
chairman in that country in that region
um he said
i just want to ask some questions there
we understand it's
about china yeah yeah yeah
yeah yes yes and you know they spoke to
the chairman
yeah one of your ceos stephen uh
wollenstein if announced his name
and i asked him a question they said are
you also good yeah
we're alan okay sorry so what's the
difference
well we're all in day and we sell
australian products yes we're not vast
regular manufacturing but you're still
buying their products so skoda
yeah yeah it might not sink no
definitely but you're still buying the
products and there's forced labor
involved and these people have been in
concentration camps that work
and nazi germany you need to talk to us
yeah but you're selling their products
but do you not think they're filming our
people are you no no no i'm just i'm
just filming them
no but from the two jewish guys
just filming them yeah yeah yeah but
obviously your cars are in there because
i can't help
but don't be filming any of our people
no no no i'm not but i'm saying do you
not think that's wrong because what
happened in nazi germany that's too
jewish
yeah but these policies they're causing
people's lives
and there's lots of things you can
comment on where things are costing
people's lives
yeah yeah well of course i talked about
that i've done it i'm on youtube i do
videos about it
so you do not believe it's right or
wrong no comment
okay well this will continue by the way
here's other volkswagen retailers no
we'll be going through this it's not
it's not city gate no we are registered
yes
we always go with lots of them we're
going to one of them but it's to raise
awareness
because there's 200 over 200 volkswagen
retailers in the country yes of course
but imagine if there was like jewish
people or concentration camps
you will be enforced labor and you're
sending the products here i'm not going
to go at you
i'm going to be making that i'm not
going to get you i'm just i'm just
trying to raise awareness what my stance
on what you're is about you need to
speak to me head office which is
volkswagen
well where is that milton keynes is the
head office okay so is the head office
that's volkswagen's head office
office there i'm sure if you speak to
them from milton keynes yeah
thank you for your time and once again
i'm not blaming you i'm not saying you
know
we all thank you so guys as you can see
um
yeah so i came here because it's
important for us to put this kind of
pressure broken sisters
um and ask them these questions
because yes he's saying we are alan dave
we're not
volkswagen but the point is regardless
what you are
it's it's you're selling these products
imagine if jewish people were in camps
in nazi germany
and they were selling um and by the just
you guys know it was actually i think in
hitler's regime
is when they set up the vote volkswagen
they found a mistake and i was reading
an article
so imagine just imagine guys if jewish
people are in concentration were in
concentration camps
and this was happening yeah and imagine
those products were being sold and if i
came and said
oh it's my shop i might add our shop uh
i'm just sending the product
it doesn't really work i'm not really
having to go at them but the issues we
have to raise
awareness uh about this so that's
exactly what we're doing here
and he did say that one second let me
get my
hidden mic there you go i've done some
james bond stuff yeah so
guys i went inside um and i tried to
speak to them
i know they're trying to make a living i
know they're trying to do their job but
the point is this we need to raise
awareness
because you see these people these two
jewish guys here andrew and daniel
yeah in about sunset it's gonna be it's
gonna be their
uh it's gonna be their sabbath they've
come here out their way trying to raise
awareness why because their ancestors
went through this
so it's only right as muslims with a
little time that i had
i came here and filmed and i had so much
stuff to do but i had to
at least film this and raise awareness
to you guys the least you guys can do
now is please
share this video that's all i'm asking
you raise awareness
the more pressure we put and the more
their pockets get hurt
they are definitely going to do
something about it in trouble if this
was your family members in concentration
camps
you would not be sleeping at night and
i'm not asking you not to sleep at night
i'm asking you to share this uh so we're
here with andrew again uh andrew
this doesn't look like the chinese
embassy to me what are you doing in
front of volkswagen
is it that you don't like their cars why
is it no i've got nothing against
volkswagen
i'm sure they're i mean they are
brilliant cars but uh
volkswagen is the only one volkswagen is
the only western brand
with a factory in xinjiang openly
and that's unacceptable it's there is
three million
plus women men children
in concentration camps and enslaved
labor there
okay and we've got to get them out and
volkswagen have got to take that factory
out of things again okay so as far as i
know i read an article on bbc
and it was they spoke to the um
the chairman in that area volkswagen
he said something which kind of got me a
little bit concerned where he was saying
that as far as i know that's not
happening
how do you feel when somebody is talking
about something that
your ancestors went through and imagine
speaking to a
fantasy in that's in germany to one of
the soldiers and they say no as far as i
know i don't think jesus
concentration comes that is what
resonated with me when he was seeing
this as if he's like well i don't i
don't think it's happening
ali that's why i'm i'm here today you
can still see the black and white red
cross
news reels and other news reels from the
late 1930s
of the nazi concentration camps with the
jews in
picture perfect everybody's smiling
this was the precursor to millions
of people being killed women children
men
being killed of all sorts it was
it was genocide it's happened once
before in history on this scale
and it's potentially happening again now
and we've got to stop it
exactly the guys from volkswagen are
pretty upset and knocked
about us and then they should we we got
nothing against them they're upset about
you yeah because we're we're affecting
their business well good
well i mean i i feel sorry for them but
yeah yeah but they need to tell their
franchisor or volkswagen
that what they're doing is it's
unacceptable and get that factory out of
single yang as soon as they do that
we'll stop
protesting